- So I am a flute teacher
for ages seven and up
at Wharton Institute
for the Performing Arts
in Berkeley Heights New Jersey.
- That's amazing.
- I love my job so much.
And I requested this song
because it really spoke to me.
I felt like it really
was about missing someone
or the memories of someone
that you're not able to be
with in-person at this time.
And I'm really feeling that
because I haven't seen
my students in person
since March of 2020.
- Yeah.
- I've been giving them
their lessons on Zoom.
So that's been interesting,
but I cannot wait to be
back with them in person
and give them big hugs.
- Aw I love you so much and I love as well
that you use the word interesting.
I have found more teachers
and parents doing homeschool
have used the word interesting.
And interesting is really
just code for really super,
a word I shouldn't say
on television right now.
But.
(Kelly laughs)
'Cause it's hard.
I am like whoa.
- Girl, it is hard.
- Interesting isn't my
word of choice.
It's just so hard to get
them to focus you know,
in general in the classroom.
And then you've.
(Kelly giggles)
And my daughter does this thing,
I don't know if any of
y'all have these kids.
She's actually, it's quite
funny, she will do this.
And just pretend that her screen.
She's six!
She's six, and she literally,
I caught her just being like.
(audience laughs)
And she'll just pretend like she's frozen
so she doesn't have to do
what they're asking her to do.
And I'm like I mean points for the comedy,
but reel it in dude.